has covered extensively the instability
in sudana he joins us now
um Hashem among the things that you've
been working on uh the last what 24 48
hours is these jailbreaks and who's been
released from jail what it might mean
for the country's future what it would
change the the political landscape one
name hame harun who is he one of the
reasons why people are pretty much
concerned when they saw that audio tape
from Ahmad Haroon about him leaving the
prison
is basically this is a key artist
architect of the old political
establishment that prevailed in Sudan
for more than four decades under
President Omar al-Bashir
and people insisted the pro-democracy
movement in 2019 that all those people
should be prosecuted sent to jail for
the atrocities committed against the
Sudanese people and for the embezzlement
of public funds one of them is
been on top of the list of the former
ICC prosecutor
he has been accused of committing
atrocities against civilians in Darfur
back in the early years of 2000s
now why people are concerned hamity on
one hand is saying that al-burhan and
his top lieutenants are allowing the
former members of the old regime
back into Political life because they
would like to build alliances with them
to tilt the ground into their own favor
the Army on the other hand blames hemety
for colluding with the old guards we're
talking about
Military Officers Intelligence Officers
tribes band clerics all affiliated with
the old political establishment and
they're saying that these are our people
who could stage a political comeback we
have to remind our viewers that back in
2019 when the pro-democracy erupted in
Sudan one of the key components or key
demands of that democracy movement is
that Omar al-bashirat all his AIDS
should be sent to jail should be banned
from returning to political life and
should be prosecuted for all the
atrocities committed against people of
Sudan so in a way or another there is a
fear that the old gods could be staging
a comeback so you see the fighting
between the Army and the rapid support
forces could now reopen this space that
had been closed ever since uh Omar
al-Bashir was ousted I have to say they
try to distance themselves from but they
are a product of um
was a product of Omar al-basia same
thing foreign
also was a product of a military coup
Sudan has had some how 17 attempted
coups a record number in the African
country and it's been run by the
military almost all of its exactly since
back in 1958 all the way through named
the only difference in 1989 was this
alliance between Robert basil and
political Islam Hassan
now you could ask me why people are
concerned Saudi Arabia and the United
Arab Emirates Post 9 2011 were the out
of spring they saw an impressive rise of
political Islam one of the key bastians
of political Islam
is Sudan and this explains why right
after 2019 we saw many Regional key
players providing significant assistance
to al-bruhan and hemeti hoping that
these two key figures could ensure that
political Islam would never stage a
comeback to the country and this
explains why the narrative Yesterday
since Yesterday in Sudan who is to blame
and are they trying to State a political
comeback whose interest would this be in
because you've got the two fighting
sides right you've got the Army under Mr
Rohan you've got the rsf under himiti
who would have a strategic interest in
perhaps seeing the Renaissance of
political Islam and the Old Guard both
in a way or another they would they
would benefit from this for the simple
reason
was larger than life as uh as as the
architect of the political Islam in
Sudan and he managed to build alliances
across ethnic lines Regional lines
religious lines and components of that
status quo or that establishment are
still in Sudan now imagine look at the
situation now al-burhan is quite obvious
he doesn't have really huge control over
the military establishment and situation
on the ground guess what tomorrow with
the backing from many people affiliated
with the old uh Old Guard it would pave
the way for him to stage a comeback
consolidate his grip on power
hemeti understands very well this and he
knows as well that there is absolutely
no way for hemetry someone who comes
from Darfur he is just beholden to one
single family enough what suddenly you
want to become president of Sudan you
won't be able to do this we need to
expand his power base if you want to do
it you have to go back to the old God
that has been there for four decades in
Sudan you want to have their backing and
you have to show loyalty for them to be
able to State a political comeback so
this explains why the story over the
last few hours the incident has been
about where is Omar al-bashia and where
are his alkalides are they still in jail
and those who left who was to be
beholden response taken responsible for
this and I think the narrative over the
last few hours is quite fascinating is
about this ongoing political divide but
also about those who collude or pull the
strings from behind closed doors
thank you so much